[Music]
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
seven prediction video in this video I
want to take a closer look at one
specific scene that took place during
the season 7 trailer that I think most
people overlooked this video will
contain spoilers with references to the
plot league so you have been warned my
friends but near the end of the season 7
trailer we see one quick scene of a man
jumping into the water as fire ax shoots
across the water above most of us who
broke down and analyzed this trailer
assumed that this was going to be fian
Greyjoy making his escape from the
attack led by euron greyjoy
I even initially thought it was fian
making his escape
but after I rewatched this scene several
times I think I know exactly who this is
and what's taking place let's examine
the evidence that I have and let me know
if you come to the same conclusion let's
get started at the beginning of season 7
we are going to get a very explosive
Greyjoy civil war that's taking place
out at sea last season euron greyjoy
showed back up at the Iron Islands and
upon arrival he murdered his brother
Balin Greyjoy who was the king of the
Iron Islands
soon after the Kings Moon which is a
ceremony where the iron Islanders choose
their next king during that Kingsmoot
euron greyjoy won over the crowd and
became king which led the Yara and Theon
fleeing the islands with Euron's best
ships when your on realized this he
decided he was going to murder his niece
and nephew so he asked his men to build
him the biggest fleet which they will
use to hunt them down but luckily for
Theon and Yara they were able to forge a
new alliance with Daenerys Targaryen who
will currently have the largest army in
Westeros plus three really big-ass
dragons but that is still not enough to
stop your own Greyjoy from attempting to
conquer anyone in his path and as of
right now Theon and Yara are sailing
with Danny's fleet heading straight for
Westeros
when season 7 begins I think you're on
woah I've caught up with them in the
very first episode I think episode 1 is
going to start off with a bang and set
the tone and pays for the entire season
into season seven trailer we got
multiple scenes of this battle taking
place in the first shot we get is of
your own ship silence which will most
likely lead the attack out on the sea
Euron is going to be almost an
unstoppable force
because this is what he does best and I
think he is going to rip through
Daenerys his Greyjoy and Martell flee we
get another quick scene of Theon Greyjoy
who is looking very scared in my trailer
breakdown I told you that I think this
is Theon watching the attack as it takes
place and he is in shock and freezing up
not knowing what to do then we get
another scene of the ship on fire and
men tearing through everyone in sight
and I think this is what vielen is
looking at and at some point during this
attack Theon will make his escape and
make it back to shore we've seen from
Leake set photos that Theon arrives on
what it's most likely Dragonstone and
upon his arrival he has a heated
confrontation with Jon Snow so at first
glance when we see this man jump into
the water as fire shoots out above its
head it's easy to assume that this is
Theon jumping into the water I know I
initially thought that but when you take
a closer look you can see that whoever
is jumping into this water is doing it
when the Sun is out if you pause the
video and look above the water you can
see the natural sunlight shining through
the water and when Theon is under attack
it is pitch-black outside so this was
Theon jumping into the water you would
not be seeing this sunlight coming
through the water by the looks of the
battle that Theon is in there is no way
that he would be able to stay on board
of his ship until the Sun rises he's
going to have to escape immediately and
also when the man jumps into the water
take a look at the fire that shoots
across the water I do not think that is
fired from a ship explosion to me that
looks like dragon fire shooting across
the water I think that is a dragon
trying to kill whoever this is jumping
into the water and when the fire shoots
across the water you can see that it
shoots out exactly like a dragon's fire
does almost in a straight line watch how
the fire shoots out at the man in the
water then watch out when a Dany's
dragons fire shoots out it looks exactly
the same to me and after this man jumps
into the water and the fire shoots
across then the trailer goes to black
and you can even hear a dragon roar very
loud but you're probably thinking who
would this dragon be trying to kill that
would make them want to put it in the
trailer I think this is Jane
olanta star going into the water after
he is nearly killed by one of Daenerys
dragons there are actually several
different reasons I think this is Jaime
Lannister the main reason is because of
the plot leaked now I don't know how
closely some of you have been paying
attention to it but the plot link
appears to be almost completely accurate
at this point after I watch this trailer
over and over again pretty much
everything we see in the trailer was in
the plot leaked all the way back in
October and if you've been subscribed to
my channel for a long time then you know
that I reported on and analysed
everything that has came out regarding
to the spoilers and after I put it all
together and look at it I think it's all
true episode four of the plot League
says that Jaime and Bronn in the
Lannister army are going to be ambushed
by Dany the Dothraki and her dragons
while marching back from Highgarden the
Lannister army gets defeated and Jaime
is almost killed by the Dragons but
Bronn saves his life and I think that's
exactly what we are seeing in this scene
when the man goes into the water I think
this is Jaime Lannister barely escaping
the Dragon Fire based off all the
evidence we have seen during the off
season we know all of this is going to
happen that the plot League said was
going to happen for this episode we can
even see in the trailer that the
Dothraki and at least one of her dragons
are attacking in this open field and we
also saw the Lannister army marching in
the trailer and if you look beneath
their feet you can see the grass I think
this is then marching back from
Highgarden right as they're about to be
ambushed and you can see from the
footage and photos that this battle is
going to be taking place in the middle
of the day so that lines up with it
being daytime when the person jumps into
the water and you can see that natural
sunlight shining through if you look at
the set photos you can see Jaime and
Bronn are preparing to film this battle
scene and you can even see water in
multiple images that were taken while
Jaime bran and the Dothraki were all on
set we know that Jamie is going to
conquer Highgarden
just like the plot League said he would
we've seen photos of the castle with the
Lannister flag raised to the top and
once he leaves Highgarden that's when
this scene is going to take place the
Lannister army is going to be
slaughtered by the Dothraki in the open
field and then Danny's dragons are going
to swoop in and take care of the rest
and we also get a photo from
Entertainment Weekly that shows Danny on
her dragon on the
is battlefield also when you see the man
jump into the water you can only see his
left hand which may have been done on
purpose I think considering how they pay
attention to all the details when they
construct these trailers I think they
know exactly how much to show without
giving too much away I think we may only
be seeing the left hand because it would
be obvious it was Jamie if we saw his
lifeless right hand in the water I think
they wanted us to think this was Theon
we know jamie is going to be fighting
the Dothraki and the dragons and we know
he is with Bronn on this battlefield and
we know this is going to be taking place
right beside some water and we also know
this battle is taking place in the
middle of the day so when you watch that
man jump into the water and you see the
sun shining through the water and you
can see that that fire shoots out
straight across like a dragon flame I a
hundred percent believe this is Jaime
Lannister going into the water to avoid
being killed by a dragon
I do think Theon is going to make an
escape but it's going to be in complete
darkness when he does that so you're not
going to see any natural sunlight
shining through the water like this but
comment below and tell me who you think
it is do you agree with me or do you
think it's someone completely different
than Theon or Jamie thanks for stopping
by to check out the video a special
thanks to all the people that support
the channel on patreon I'll see you all
down below bye